salman sagar celebrates with his
supporters
the former mayor of srinagar won two
constituencies in kashmir's capital
he stood as a candidate for the
anti-modi opposition coalition
gupta alliance this is the toughest ever
election i have fought because we were
not allowed to campaign
we were not allowed to meet people we
were not allowed to talk to people we
were not given proper security proper
permissions to hold rallies
these local elections were the first
since new delhi stripped the autonomy of
indian-administered kashmir last year
effectively annexing parts of the
disputed territory
india's decision to revoke self-rule in
the majority-muslim-populated region
caused anger and many kashmiris say they
used these elections to make their
voices heard
the gupkar alliance won 110 of the 280
contested seats
but members of india's governing hindu
nationalist bjp
say they're also celebrating the party
won
74 seats making it the single largest
winner
[Music]
this is a victory for the bjp i believe
it is because of the popularity of prime
minister narendra modi in our towns and
villages
the people have faith in our prime
minister and i believe in the future we
will witness development
the people who wanted to spread
communism have failed
but the goop car alliance says the
election results show a majority of
people want the region's special status
to be restored
the bjp says the results vindicate the
2019
constitutional changes
modi's government has said uniformity
and rules and governance will bring
development but many kashmiris insist
the region must have its autonomy
and right to determine its future
victoria gatenby al jazeera